[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il fallait que je teste ça il le fallait
sylvie et chimie mais six d'entre
[Musique]
elles auraient compris sont complètement
cassé c'est plus que c'est moi qui parle
pas de caprices du milieu
alors vous n'avez que deux options
première option vous restez que votre
femme jusqu'à la fin de vos jours je
prendre la 2ème la deuxième
je n'avais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
tout est beau
ma thèse
[Musique]
est ce qu ont suivi des pressions bah en
fait pour être tout à fait honnête avec
vous je crois qu'il ya aucun patron
aucun ministre qui osent m'appeler sur
mon téléphone porter parce qu'ils sont
tous persuadés que j'enregistre toutes
mes conversations téléphoniques et là
dessus d'ailleurs je vais laisser un
léger flou peut-être que c'est vrai en
fait les pressions et s'exerce plus tôt
là-haut tout là-haut à la direction de
france télévisions et la plupart du
temps on n'en parle pas donc c'est
plutôt un bon signal de la part de
france télévisions nous laisse
travailler tranquillement après il y a
quand même de l'intimidation de grosses
sociétés qui ne veulent pas nous
accorder des interviews et qui font tout
pour que nos enquêtes ne sortent pas
mais elle bat comme vous ne connaissez
ça nous donne plutôt envie de les sortir